200 jahre ist es her da taumelte skandal
durch florenz einer ohnmacht nahe
überwältigt von der pracht gott wie ist
das schön
bei jeder einzelheit die ich erblickte
geriet meine seele mehr in entzücken
ich war auf dem punkt der begeisterung
angelangt wo sich die himmlischen
empfindungen wie sie die kunst bietet
mit leidenschaftlichen gefühlen gattin
ich befand mich in einer art ekstase
hier klopft das herz mein lebensquell
war versiegt und ich fürchtete um zu
fallen
was total erlebte passiert noch heute
gerade in florenz scheinen reisende
besonders anfällig für das sogenannte
stendhal syndrom auch die florentinische
krankheit genannt
die psychiatrische klinik von florenz
hat über die jahre verschiedenste fälle
dokumentiert
so berühmt wurde das phänomen dass es
sogar zu einem spielfilm inspirierte
die symptome sind vielfältig schwindel
atemnot panikattacken bis hin zu
wahnvorstellungen und ohnmacht
viele gehen nach florenz in die uffizien
haben sich ein bisschen vorbereitet und
stehen dann plötzlich vor der fülle und
sie sind schon in einem zustand
vielleicht extremer offenheit und dann
passiert das was ich nenne eine art
überarbeitung der seele so viel gefühle
hintereinander sind schwer zu verdauen
besonders wenn einzelne wildert eine
innere gefühlslage treffen und die noch
verstärken
der psychoanalytiker thema noser weiß
von der wirkung der kunst auf die psyche
und die kann offenbar fatal sein
es wird von sexuellen identitätskrisen
berichtet beim anblick des bacchus von
caravaggio von flammenden herzen und
köpfen beim besuch von michelangelos
david von menschen die durch die straßen
irren und ihren namen vergessen haben
alles überstrapazierte seelen
oder gibt es vielleicht ganz simple
erklärungen für das phänomen liegt es
nicht schlicht am gedränge in den
touristenmassen
an der schlechten luft in den museen
oder führt gar der städte blick nach
oben zu einem blutstau im nacken
für zarte gemüter reicht das allemal für
einen schwindelanfall der
psychoanalytiker vermutet eine besondere
verfassung als ursache für die
überreizung manche menschen sind schon
wenn sie ins museum gehen in einer
anderen stimmung hellwach die seele
reagierte schon vorher nicht erst beim
kartenkauf sondern heute gehen wir ins
museum
das ist fast für manche wir in einen
gottesdienst gehen oder in ein richtiges
abenteuer und in dieser bereitschaft der
seele bilder anzuschauen stellt sich
auch die innere konflikt lage da kunst
öffnet also entführt uns in die tiefen
des unbewussten
aber keine sorge die symptome klingen
bald ab und hinterlassen keine
bleibenden schäden
die fachleute raten ruhe bewahren in der
heimatsprache sprechen und in schweren
fällen florenz möglichst schnell
verlassen
doch es muss nicht immer in einem drama
enden
in der regel ist die beschäftigung mit
kunst eine wohltuende seelenmassage die
man sich möglichst oft können sollte
gelegenheit dazu bietet etwa die courbet
ausstellung in der fondation beyeler und
wenn einem dabei ein leichter schwindel
gefällt so kann man sich doch eigentlich
glücklich schätzen denn dann hat die
kunst das innerste berührt und so das
äußerste erreicht